hi everyone I'm David Griffin now
Michael Medina you were to bring you the
arrow season 2 episode 21 city of blood
review getting close to the end here
almost there rich title city of blood
alluding to you know miss brother blood
you know in his reign is mayor now had
to be honest this episode was a little
disappointing how so it was a point in
that this is the final three episodes we
have two more after this I wanted more
to happen I thought this was just
everybody morning Moira as they should
because Moira was great i'm sad that
she's gone but I feel like nothing
really happened I felt like I said if
you watch this show from you know from
the beginning till now and you skipped
this episode and just watched the
following the last two I feel like you
dis episodes not even needed this really
felt like filler to me what do you think
I don't I think it we will watch this
one together yeah I I felt that way
initially but then I think in the end
like when after I finished watching the
episode I thought about I'm like you
know I think there are a lot of pieces
that were moving around in this
particular episode the episode obviously
was setting up the finale exactly and I
think that's why I kind of enjoy that
because it's like we have what like two
more episodes left you left so I'm sure
those two episodes are going to be nuts
and stuff so I think this episode was it
served at a trick as a transition from
like the events that happened with Moira
setting up like their escape from the
other attempted escape we don't know if
they actually get up obviously was five
years or so right but um you know I
thought it worked well as far as I said
in the stage for what happens next
because you know a lot of what does
happen in this episode it's not there's
a little bit of action you know kind of
gets cut off towards the end and we can
talk about that later on it's tough but
again I just thought it was really good
at like moving a lot of pieces and
setting the stage for the grand finale
yeah I just thought I just for me I
didn't think we learned that much I
guess that was my I guess I'm I'm at a
point in the show now I'm fine with
small character moment episodes I don't
need a lot of action all the time but
this is the last three like this should
be go out with a bang here and I guess
find out wally or uh Holly sorry Wally
going to get ahead of myself here find
out all he has a you know a secret lair
yeah wasn't that it's pretty convenient
seeing us out the club was taken away
right oh the club's gone
oh my god on my club yeah we see what's
in a yeah she's uh you know all she
can't even get on the hyssop flood you
know go on coach yeah at the airport via
no money but we learned that I mean in I
guess we do get to see summer glau is
ravager but like we Mike and I you guys
to the comment and we've been taught
with this for weeks now we knew this was
coming so surprised i think i'd seen
some images after the fact right off the
night but actually seeing it in motion
not impressed by the outfit what it
seems she's like very small figures yeah
the hell the mask looks too big for her
yeah it's a little more like sleek like
black canary has or like like Mesa yeah
and I don't know maybe it's just me but
it feels almost a little hokey almost
like adam west batman at all of
Deathstroke's minions wear the mask
right car might be of a batman the dark
knight rises with bein in his minions
yeah the far horizon i reminded me of
that a little bit yeah yeah but um you
know we did it wasn't monster kind of a
pretty big reveal like his Laurel you
know is reveals to Oliver that she knows
the identity and had known because of
you know what Slade told her but again
my beef is to push back is that we knew
that she knew so yeah I guess I'm
complaining a lot and I know I'm
probably should stop also though another
thing that bothered me a little bit as a
side story with Felicity and Diggle you
know our boy Diggle there do it a little
more than it usually does doing more
than going and getting burgers but it
just like the whole like you know
interrogation scene with Felicity I
guess it's supposed to be cute like them
trying to find Oliver going to visit
what's name there over there at uh uh
Cynthia died Robbins character oh yeah
I'm uh wallet walleye one is Amanda
Waller like they just walk in like hey
we need some help you know so I don't
know it's just I just feel like if I
skip this episode and then watch the
last two I don't think I would have
missed much but again you know when you
do 23 episodes there's a lot that has to
get done but I mean I'm so is he liked
it though you get I did enjoy I guess I
kind of just viewed this episode is like
you know part one of them now to the
Slayer Ezra Parker you know that that's
just how I saw maybe that's why I was
just a little more
giving it yeah if it were like middle of
the season right yeah I think it would
totally just been filler whatnot but i
just thought at least it set the stage
and I thought in a good way because then
Oliver does it was really cool scene
where Oliver confronts Sebastian blood
at the restaurant tell you know I know
that you're working for Slade and you
know this is what's going to go down if
you don't pull back and Kevin Alejandro
I really do like him I think he's a good
actor I was nice seeing him back in the
fold doing all this stuff but okay i
guess i don't know i was just i think
the promise to my can i watch this up so
late in the week and some of our friends
and co-workers were calming the city
this episode's ok you know so i think in
my head I was like okay what am I
getting in myself into and you liked it
and I guess I saw and I think I just
kind of agreed with them I just thought
it was more filler than not but there's
a lot of good things to look forward to
you see the preview in the episode it
looks like we're going to see Malcolm
merlyn's coming back I'm sure Nisa will
come back black in there it's going to
be I think these last episode's going to
be great whether or not you like some
sort or not I think this is last we're
going to be excellent episode I'm hoping
they have to be because like I said I
mean that ending you know sequence and
stuff there's a little bit of a fiber
tell it's like cut early there'll be a
whole lot more like you know it's gonna
hit the fan basically and I can't wait
for that right so I mean this episode
you know that's what we thought of this
week's episode it's not as much as we
normally talk about I think I guess I
was a little underwhelmed I wish more
happened i mean this this was a stage
set er well you you know like they're
not it's set setting the stage for
what's eventually about to happen which
should be exciting two more episodes
left next week in the week after so no
more breaks again like we've been talked
about the last few weeks so you know so
my can I thought of this week's episode
you know as always you can come chat
with us at think yo calm it also can
find on this YouTube page it's a think
hero pro be sure to LIKE subscribe you
know I'll leave your feedback we always
like to get to your comments and
everything and we're also both of us on
twitter if i'm up to dennis michael and
myself we're all it think hero i'm at
griffin de i'm at i'm mr. michael Alexis
and you can also find us on Facebook
have a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans will see you next
week
you